transactions your organization processes
millions of them all through your data
power array but some fail or get blocked
for security reasons and since
transaction details are only stored
momentarily it is impossible to track
down errors and determine their root
cause especially when you have many data
power gateways each failure may occur on
a different date of power Gateway and by
the time it is located it's details are
already gone
sometimes errors are so elusive they
require several staff members forcing
you to spend precious time and money on
troubleshooting and error reproduction
while trying to maintain customer SLA
although there are tools that may alert
for errors they can't provide sufficient
information for real-time
troubleshooting in short operational
nightmare the solution IBM data power
Operations dashboard designed by data
power experts IBM data power Operations
dashboard offers you real-time access to
your transactions regardless of the
number of your data power gateways using
Big Data technology
IBM data power Operations dashboard
stores detailed logs of each transaction
enabling you to track down any error no
matter when it occurred and it doesn't
stop there it also provides statistical
dashboards
trend analysis and real time alerts have
hidden errors so invest our resources
where it counts as well even your
customers a new level of service empower
your data power with IBM data power
Operations dashboard